Hello, and welcome to today's episode of Rawkode
live. I am your host,
Rawkode.
Today, we're gonna be taking a look at
Suborbital,
a platform from running web assembly applications.
And I am joined today by the creator,
Connor Hicks. Hey, Connor. How are you?
I'm doing well. How are you? Yes. Very
well. Thank you. Not too bad. Not too
bad at all. I know it's early for
you. So thank you very much for taking
the time out of your day and and
joining us today.
My pleasure.
So
I gave a very brief introduction to what
Suborbital is. It's a platform for running web
assembly applications.
And do
you wanna just give us a little bit
of more flavor on that? And I I
believe you've got some slides to help us
through that as well.
I sure do. Let's try to get this
up and running here.
Yeah. So
I will start sharing those and then I'll
give you a little bit more information.
Yeah. And I was really rude. And like
I said in that little intro video there,
I I always mess up the intro. I
forgot to even ask you to introduce yourself.
Do you wanna give us a little bit
about you as well, You know what? That's
the second slide, so we can just go
right into that. Oh, perfect. There you go.
Alright.
Yeah. So hi. My name is Connor Hicks.
I
by day, I work for one password. I
lead a team called platform, product discovery, I
should say.
We do research and development, for new products.
And, for the last year or so, I've
been working on Suborbital.
And Suborbital's,
goal is to allow building
web
services,
APIs
using,
functions
that are compiled to WebAssembly.
And
so, you know, it's been
there's been several iterations
of the project.
Originally, it actually used Docker,
to facilitate,
you know, the the actual running of the
functions. But about a year ago, I I
decided that it just wasn't
it it wasn't working the way that I
wanted it to. Everything was
overcomplicated.
There were components that
I didn't like how they were designed. So
I decided to pivot, if you will, and
and switch to WebAssembly. So I'll back up
for a second and talk about the actual
problem that a developer is facing that, you
know, I'm actually trying to solve here regardless
of the technology being used.
And it's really that, you know,
building web services
has gotten more and more complex
over the last couple of years, right, the
last ten years even.
Everything is microservices
or, you know, having to string together these
these complicated serverless platforms.
And
I'm I'm really having a focus on simplicity.
The the actual the tagline
for Suborbital
is
build web services that are powerful but never
complicated.
That's kind of the the
the line that I've been using.
And so I really want to make it
easier to get a production web service up
and running
with with a lot, you know, less fuss.
So,
actually, there's the tagline.
So, yeah, I am building for a future
based on WebAssembly.
I've been coming up with this thing called
the SUFA design pattern,
that stands for simple unified function based applications.
And I can go through a bit more
of what that's all about a little later,
but the the basic idea is,
let's make it easy to deploy,
make it so that you only have to
deploy one thing, you know, unified
function based because I think that's a great
paradigm.
And then,
application
meaning having a very specific meaning of it
is one program
that is serving your entire application. You don't
have multiple services
that are serving the same thing. You can
segment
your application logic using the functions rather than
using individual
services.
And one of my goals is to really
embrace the edge computing movement that's been that's
been going on.
Things like Cloudflare Workers and and Fastly
ComputeEdge,
they're starting to take advantage of WebAssembly on
the edge.
I do think that there's, you know,
another couple steps further that we can take
to really take advantage of that, and I'll
talk about, you know, how later.
And then one of the founding,
like, principles of just me as a developer
is that make
make libraries and and
and frameworks and such hard to use wrong.
Right? There are lots of things that you
can
you know, there's a lot of libraries that
you can get that you can configure every
single little nut and bolts down in the
guts of the system.
And
sometimes you can shoot yourself in the foot
with that because the maintainer,
you know, allowed you to configure something that
you shouldn't have been able to configure, and
you can, you know, introduce security vulnerabilities or
whatever by by misconfiguring something. So it's one
of the one of the big goals to
make that hard to do.
So Suborbital is actually a family of projects.
The the main one,
the one that we're gonna talk about most
today is ATMO.
It's kind of the the batteries included
project, if you will. It has,
all of the, the WebAssembly runtime.
All of the all of the three projects
you see at the bottom are put together
to form ATMO, kinda like the Voltron
robot.
So there's there's Hive, which is a a
job scheduler or a function scheduler.
And this is where the WebAssembly,
you know,
the main parts happen
are in the the job scheduler.
It uses Wasmr
under the hood to,
to run WebAssembly modules.
But what Hive does is it actually makes
it multitenant,
and it manages the execution
and memory
and
communication
of
many, many, many modules all at once.
And
so that's kind of the core of ATMO.
It can be all three of these building
blocks, if you will, they can be used
on their own if you wish.
But Atmo is kind of the plug and
play all in one. You don't need to
do anything yourself get it up and running.
And then Vector is is a is an
API framework for Go.
It does,
you know, just make it a little bit
easier to build, API servers. It's
it's something that I built for myself,
and for, you know, just making it,
quicker to bootstrap a Go web service without
all the boilerplate that you normally need.
And then Grav
is,
it's my kinda my my favorite little project
of the bunch.
It's a distributed
I call it a messaging mesh.
So you can think of it like a
message bus, kind of like Kafka,
but it is completely decentralized.
It takes
plug ins for transport
and and node discovery. So,
anybody could write a plug in to, you
know, use a particular transport,
a particular protocol, or whatever to, to do
the messaging.
But it is really designed to allow,
scaling up, you know, large groups of instances
to to communicate asynchronously with one another.
So I just wanted to quickly touch on
WebAssembly itself
and say, you know, there's been a pretty
big movement coming up, over the last little
while,
for WebAssembly, not just in the web browser,
but also in more of a server side
context.
And I've got a couple of examples here.
You know, the the founder of Docker,
this is a quote that anybody working in
server side WebAssembly will probably quote at some
point in their, in their tenure,
which is that, you know, if WASM and
Wazee existed in 02/2008, we wouldn't have needed
to create Docker. You know, it's it's a
pretty good
endorsement, I think, from from the, the CEO
of Docker.
And then, you know, the CNCF,
showed WebAssembly as, one of the five technologies
to watch in 2021.
And there's a whole bunch of open source
work being done right now. I'm gonna show
off a couple of things,
today, I think, couple of projects,
obviously, including the suborbital projects as well. But
things like Crustlet,
that's one of my favorite projects. I think
it's so cool. They were able to
basically emulate
a what they call the virtual cubelet,
which is tricking Kubernetes not tricking, but plugging
into Kubernetes
to make it think that you're running regular
workloads when really it's running WebAssembly workloads.
It was entirely written in Rust.
There was a big splash about it a
couple of months ago. I think it's pretty
cool. So there's lots of projects like that
that are coming up and making me really
believe that WebAssembly is kind of the next
the next big thing.
And so I'll I'll just close out the
slides by saying, you know, I'm I'm looking
for anybody who's interested in coming and working
on this.
It's been mostly just me for the last
year or so.
People are starting to try it out. People
are starting to get really interested in it,
but,
you know, I'm I am anybody who's interested
in coming to help out, I really appreciate
it. And, I am running a little survey.
I wanna know what people
want to get out of a WebAssembly,
server side framework.
So bit.ly/wildinsurvey.
It'll take three minutes to fill out, and
I'd love to get
everyone's feedback.
So with that, I think we can get
right into it.
Awesome.
Yeah.
Definitely. That was that was really cool. I
think,
yeah, everyone's gonna quote that Solomon thing at
some point I think over the next few
years because it's a very powerful statement to
say that, you know,
what is now become almost a ubiquitous way
of running language
and runtime agnostic
applications
on bare metal and virtual machines. The containers
wouldn't be needed to put Wasm and
I mean, it's not hyperbole is it? Like
Wasm really does have the potential to change
the way that we build applications within the
next five to ten years. And Wasi I
think It absolutely does. Super exciting as well.
I was really disappointed obviously with the Mazzella
layoffs last year. It looked like I wasn't
sure if Wazi was gonna pull through and
then literally just yesterday my calendar bleeped with
the invite to the next Wazi meeting and
I was like really excited to see that
come back to life again.
Yeah. Yeah. Absolutely.
And the Crustlet project. I think I actually
wrote an article on that last year as
well. Really really cool thing as well. I
was so happy when I got that running.
And now we get to look at more
web assembly stuff. Like it's definitely one of
my favorite technologies It's just hovering on that
fringe right now of really awesome things. So
this is exciting.
Yeah. Yeah. And that's something I want everybody
to to realize. Like, this this technology is
still very, very young.
There's
there's not, you know, been the the same
level of adoption on the server side as
it has had on the browser so far.
But the amount of work that the community
is putting into it right now really makes
me believe that it is, like you said,
in the next five, ten years gonna be
a a really big deal. Yeah, definitely.
Alright. Thank you for that introduction. That was
great.
Why don't we
get started then? Let's see where it is.
Ta da. I have this Suborbital
homepage.
So we're gonna be taking a look at
Atmo. Atmo is the all in one batteries
included component of Suborbital.
I
guess I'm just gonna click get started and
we're we're gonna work through.
Yes. So this is my like, I just
kind of relaunched the documentation for Atmo last
weekend.
So, you know, we wanted probably one of
the first people to be going through it
in full.
It used to all live in the GitHub
repo and now it's got its own its
own home. So, yeah, we can hopefully take
advantage of it today.
Yeah. Yeah. Definitely. Yeah. I don't think these
were here the last time I looked.
So
the first thing I need to So if
you can actually pause on the welcome screen,
I do wanna point out something at the
bottom of that page.
So
this is where we come back to the
simplicity part of it. The the three bullet
points you see there is really
it it sums up the goal for using
Atmo
is that you you should be able to
get up and running with an Atmo application
that is
I I'm gonna say the word production ready
a couple of times throughout the stream, but
let's realize that Atmo is still in alpha.
So when I say production ready, it will
be production ready when Atmo is production ready.
So you write these these self contained composable
functions, and what that means is
all the functions you're gonna write are gonna
be completely unaware of one another. They are
meant to be running in isolation,
and they interact with the outside world using
the suborbital APIs.
And then you we're gonna look at something
called the directive, and that's how you build
applications with Atmo. And it's a declarative
file.
And I I'm really excited about this part
of it, and I'm excited to show it
off because I think it's a really cool
way of building web web applications.
And then at the end, once we've built
our functions and our directive, we're gonna end
up with something that I call a runnable
bundle.
And it is a single file that you
can then use to deploy your application.
And this really goes back to the simple
unified
function based apps. It really like, those three
things is kind of the embodiment of that,
and it shows, you know, how we can
simplify building web services by taking advantage of
the property that WebAssembly gives us.
Okay.
So
is it
I like the thing in your slides where
you said, you know, kinda hard to mess
this up at least from a security perspective.
Like is that because it's what we were
what we're gonna work with is compiled down
to web assembly and we're taking advantage of
that sandbox environment or is Atmo and the
other components bring in an additional layer of
security over the top?
I think it's both, actually, because the code
that's actually handling these API requests, like you
said, it is sandboxed. It is it does
take advantage of the strong security
properties that WebAssembly
gives us.
But in addition,
you know, Atmo
is it it uses vector, that API framework,
as its, you know, way of of of
deploying the actual
web server,
and that has a bunch of security best
practices
built into it. So that is really the
goal of making it hard to screw up.
Okay.
I'd like to understand. I mean, maybe that
will make more sense when we start writing
a lot of a code but I'll throw
this out and if you think let's just
wait and see just feel free to say
that.
If a request comes in, the first thing
it hits is vector,
it works out what function has to be
called and then it speaks
to Atmo or
and then it runs the web assembly using
Wasimer
and then you said they're composable.
So how does the composition between these functions
work? Is is something capturing standard and standard
out? I know this has always been a
bit of a challenge for WebAssembly runtimes. Do
you maybe wanna give me a little insight
into that?
Yeah. Absolutely. So so, yeah, like I said,
Atmo is you can think of it as
gluing
those three building projects
together.
So
it so Vector receives the request.
It then schedules
all of the functions
that are needed to handle that request in
the Hive job scheduler.
And then,
Grav comes in,
we'll talk about a little bit later, something
called capability groups,
which
are still experimental, and we won't be able
to try them today, unfortunately. But the idea
is that individual functions
will be able to be executed on different
hosts.
And the idea behind capability groups is that
you can have privileged
instances,
some of them that have access to sensitive
resources,
like, say, your access to your payment provider
or access to a particular database. And you
can have individual functions running on those privileged
instances,
so that only a sliver of the execution
for your request is happening on those privileged
instances.
But because the whole thing is sitting on
this message bus,
that is completely transparent to the developer. So
you don't need to just you don't need
to do any logic
related
to that transfer of execution,
but it is happening
happening under the covers because the WebAssembly job
scheduler
and the message bus are all just kind
of handling that on your behalf.
Okay.
I have loads of questions, but I think
let's get started first. Let's see how it
works in practice and then maybe that'll answer
a few of those questions rather than we
bombard new with lots of trivial newbie stuff.
Let's see, we gotta get started. It says
here that we need the Suborbital
CLI.
So Yep.
Pop that open.
Yeah. For sure.
And this is already all right? All the
components are?
Yeah. That's right.
There's some some Rust stuff and some Swift
stuff that we'll look at later. But in
for the most part, it's all written in
Go.
So
Sorry, Indigo.
Yeah. So this is using
a really cool I don't know if many
people are aware of this, but it's a
service called Go Binaries.
It will allow you to automatically
build
and install any Go tool to your computer
even if you don't have a Go runtime
or Go toolchain installed. So that's how I'm
distributing it. Nice.
No. I hadn't seen that before, so that's
that's good to know. Yeah. So you should
be able to just run Suborbital dash dash
help just to make sure we've got it
installed
properly.
There we go.
So yeah. So Suborbital is the first kinda
component. This is kind of the build tool
chain for all of the Suborbital
products.
And the goal with Subo is that
you shouldn't need anything other than Subo and
Docker.
If you want to install the individual language,
you know, tools,
if you want to install
Rust and configure,
you know, the WebAssembly targets, you can, and
Subor will let you use them.
But by default, it will use Docker to
build all of your all of your functions.
So you can actually rely on it to
provide the tool chains
if you wish.
Alright.
We
we got into trouble, I'm afraid, from the
audience.
Pipe into a shell is not a good
idea. Yes. I
agree. However,
live demos, I think it's okay. Yeah.
And yeah, it's it's it's gonna be up
on package managers
at some point.
That's something that I haven't done in a
long time. I need to remind myself of
how all those different package managers distribute and
whatnot and get some automation going to distribute
that properly. But for now, I think it's
a it's an okay solution. Yeah. Definitely. I'm
I'm okay with it. I I pipe the
shelves all the time. I know I shouldn't.
So I'm
sure there'll be brew packages soon, next derivation
shortly after.
And that's why, you know, the community can
see how cool is to us and actually
go and help contribute them too. So thank
you Kelly Jack o six. You've just volunteered
to that.
Right.
Okay. So we've got the CLI and now
we need to create a project.
So we just do Suborbital create project important
API. Alright. I like it.
I'll keep the name the same.
So that says it's it's downloaded a template.
Do you wanna kinda add this? What what's
happening there? What's a template? What's a project
in this context?
Absolutely.
So there are
several different languages that you can use to
build your functions.
Currently, we have official support for Rust and
Swift and more to come. And so for
building those different functions
and for just structuring the project as a
whole, there are a number of templates,
for those empty,
you know, projects. It's never something that
you as the developer would need to care
about. They're all just managed automatically,
and they're all available in in GitHub as
well if you do want to take a
look at them. But, really, all it's doing
is,
copying a,
it's downloading a ZIP of a Git repo
in the background and then using,
the contents of that to to bootstrap these
empty things on your machine.
Okay. So we get a
project directory,
a lower directory and some source. Let's just
pop this open and and code I guess.
Yeah.
Now because this is
web assembly or at least it's compelling down
to web assembly, can I use any language
that supports web assembly for my my components?
So theoretically,
yes. However, the the Suborbital
API,
the library,
is required.
So you mentioned earlier, like, sometimes
we can do input and output using standard
in and standard out.
That's not what's happening here.
We,
there there is a full library.
You can see at the top there the
suborbital,
Rust crate
that is being imported here,
and that provides a number of
hosts and
guest
connections.
And so
all of the functionality is going through that
library.
So anytime you wanna interact with the outside
world,
that is happening through these libraries. So,
any language that has those APIs implemented
and I'll be like, they're very small APIs.
It's really just some memory management and some
input output stuff.
Any WebAssembly compatible language that has a, you
know, a library for it will work.
It's just that Rust and Swift are the
two that have that library so far.
Well, I'm not gonna argue. I'm a huge
fan and advocate of Rust right now. I'm
trying to I'm pretty much doing everything in
the rewrite in Rust bandwagon.
Sure.
So before we really hop into the function,
I'd love to take a look at that
directive dot YAML that's in the root of
the project.
So
this is what I talked about earlier with
the declarative
web application design. So this is how we're
actually gonna string together those functions, and that's
this is where the composability comes in.
So
what we're doing here is we're actually defining
the different endpoints
that our application will provide,
and then we are composing functions to handle
them. So,
you can see there
we have one route defined as post to
slash hello,
and we're calling the hello world function that
was included with the empty project to handle
that.
So as we go along, we'll and we
can add a couple more functions,
and I can show you the different ways
that those, functions can be put together to
handle and do different types of logic.
But at the end of the day, this
is kind of the entry point, if you
will, for the application. This is,
where everything is put together and controlled.
And it's nice because it is
from from my use of it, it is
a really nice abstraction.
It it really toes the line
between needing to write a lot of boilerplate
and needing to care
about, you know, what's happening under the hood.
It gives you full control of
the execution and what is happening,
but it makes it so you don't have
to care about how it's happening.
The the job scheduler,
all of the resources,
setting up of the web server, setting up
of the message bus, all of that is
completely
invisible to the developer,
and they really get to focus on the
business logic.
Nice. I like it.
Yeah. Alright. So this is we're seeing any
push request to slash hello to run a
hello function
thing. Yeah. Which is just You can pop
back to that This which is literally just
doing a print. Right? Or actually, not even
doing a print. It's formatting a string and
returning it as a as an option.
That's right. Yeah. So we're gonna start super
simple. I want us to get this up
and running to show that it is working,
and then we can start, you know, adding
some more stuff to it.
So I'll I'll walk through what's here real
quick.
So it is using the Suborbital Crate to
gain access to the Suborbital APIs,
the very basic of which is just
this runnable
trait.
So you can see that the hello world
struct is adding an implementation for that runnable
trait.
And then we expose the only required function
on that trait, which is the run function.
So whenever this function is hit by the
job scheduler,
it will give you an input, which is
just some bytes,
and then you
provide an output, which is just some more
bytes.
All of the complicated stuff, all of the
extra functionality that you get to take advantage
of is done through the API.
And
so we can pretty much, right off the
bat, just build this and run it and
show it that it's, working.
And then we can continue,
you know,
working on some I don't know if you
wanna follow my instructions or if you want
to follow the documentation,
but oh, you don't need cargo.
Oh, oh,
I was just falling into my my default
in the Wizard. So That's okay. You you
actually can like, you can use cargo if
you want to, but the the
the point of the Suborbital CLI is that
it actually abstracts all of that away from
you. So if we, dig into the build
command,
you can do build dash dash help if
you want. We can show what the options
are.
This will take all of the, I should
preface this by saying, the functions in a
suborbital project are referred to as runnables.
So a runnable,
in in the ATMO context is a WebAssembly
module. But if you were just using the
Hive job scheduler
by itself,
you can implement runnables however you want. So
you can use Go code to build runnables.
You can implement a plug in to run
Docker containers or whatever you want.
But so that's why I call them runnables,
because it is more generic if you want
it to be. But in the context of
Atmo, they are always WebAssembly modules. So if
we run Subo build and then pass dot
as the current directory and then dash dash
oh, yeah. Sure.
That's okay. We'll we'll we can get, more
into it. The so the bundle flag is
is really what we want because that's going
to create that runnable bundle that I mentioned
before. So you can hit that. Okay. And
if I do dash dash native, it'll use
my local Rust tooling. But if I don't,
it's gonna get docker based on what I
can read from here. Right? Yes.
That's exactly right.
So we can we can run the Docker
one first, and then we'll show maybe the
differences between the tool chains a little bit
later.
So we have builders,
which are Docker images for all of the
languages. Well, I say all. There's two of
them.
And the the the builder images ship with
everything that's needed
to build
your runnables. And so
we can abstract away some of the complexity
of those individual tool chains,
and make it a little bit easier for
you. The downside
of that, you know, decreased complexity
is that it's a little bit slower. As
you can see, it's having to download a
Docker image. Now it's nice because the slowness
only happens really the first time.
Once you've got all the images and once
you've, you know, done the initial compilation
of the of the runnables, the subsequent builds
are pretty fast.
However, if you were using your native tool
chain, this would already be done
thirty seconds ago. But we can continue to
talk for a few minutes while this completes
for the first time. Shouldn't take more than
a minute or two.
Well, yeah. I mean, I've got a
question that maybe is
I don't know. Glating is the wrong word.
But you've written all of the Atmo tools
in Go,
but Go isn't one of the supported run
times. Is there any reason behind that?
Yeah. Yeah. It's it's a very good point.
So
the current support for Go with WebAssembly
is not where it needs to be quite
yet. There is an alternative
Go tool chain called TinyGo that
has pretty good WebAssembly support, and I have
been experimenting with that a little bit.
But
it's it's honestly just the fact that
languages
with a simpler,
runtime and memory layout work better with WebAssembly,
and Go's
is not the simplest.
So Rust, for example, has a it has
a very very, very tiny runtime.
It has a very simple memory layout. It's
very similar to c and c plus plus.
And so it it lends itself very well
to the WebAssembly,
you know, ecosystem.
But then,
you know, once Go
releases some updates to
improve its support, I will definitely be targeting
it. It is my my language of choice
after all. So yeah. I have seen the
the conversations
around using Go and like the smallest web
assembly module compiled.
I don't wanna make up numbers, I believe
it was like maybe 30 kilobytes or something
or maybe it's the hundred. I remember it
being a weird figure and tiny go I
think they got that down substantially.
Yeah, I think I do understand that concern.
I also have some good news for our
you from the audience.
So
it's o six jelly jack actually took me
seriously when I said that was not their
responsibility and I think they've just added Subor
to the next user repository.
So you now have a next day vision
for building Subor. Thank you very much, man.
That was awesome. There we go. That's awesome.
Thank you. Alright.
So, yeah, as you can see, this first
build is
is quite slow.
Yeah. I mean, that's a Rust thing. Right?
I mean, anyone who's been compiling Rust programs
for more than half an hour is is
very familiar with the slow compilation speeds, unfortunately.
Right. Yeah. And then I think it'll be
quite,
you know, quite cool to show, like, we
can use the native tool chain after this,
and we'll show how much faster it really
can be
when you have, you know, some of the
dependencies already compiled and whatnot.
So,
hopefully, this will be done in just a
moment, and then we can actually run the
whole thing. But I'll talk about what the
bundles are first while we're while we're finishing
this up.
So the the bundle is it really ends
up as a zip file. It's nothing complicated,
really. But what it will include is it
will include your directive, the YAML file,
and it will include all of the compiled
WebAssembly
modules
into it. So what will happen is that
oh, there it goes.
You can see there the last line says
the bundle was created,
runnables dot waz and dot zip.
So what will happen is Atmo
loads this bundle at runtime. So
one
thing that I've been having trouble communicating and
that I think is might be a little
bit, you know, confuse
self is not a framework.
Atmo is actually an application that runs your
application. So it's more of a platform.
The The the framework
is really, you know, the,
the
paradigm that it allows you to build applications
with, and that is using the directive, using
the crate and the, you know, the runnable
API.
But Atmo itself is actually just loading
your application and running it.
It's a little confusing, and I've been having
trouble, like, really getting that message across clearly
because I don't even think I can talk
about it super coherently at this point. But
I hope that makes sense.
Yeah. I think so. I think it does.
Okay. So I think our next step is
to run this. Is that right? Yeah. Yeah.
So you can just do Subo dev, and
that will spin up a development server.
Oh, director. Oh, so you're inside of the
no. You're you're inside of the runnable right
now. You gotta go up a level.
Yep. Oh, yes. Next to the directive.com.
So o six Kelly Jack is is thrown
in our question as
they suggest. They may have missed it but
is there a reason that the tooling are
starting to go rather than rust? I think
the answer you kinda just said it is
that Go is your preferred language. Right?
Yeah. Yeah. I I am a professionally, like,
I am a Go developer,
and
Go is the language that I can build
things the easiest with. And it's important that
like, I do think that Go
is
an extremely good language for building web services.
And as soon as it is feasible to
do so, I will be providing a Go
runtime for first of Orbital.
But right now, it's just not possible. And
honestly, I don't think I would have been
able to build nearly as much of these
projects as I have in the year that
I've been working on it.
When it comes to building cloud native type
applications,
Rust is coming up. Absolutely. It's gonna be,
I think, one of the big ones in
the next couple years, but it's not quite
at the level of go just yet in
terms of being able to integrate with the
other things in the cloud native ecosystem.
That's not gonna be true forever, but for
now, that's kind of where I stand on
that.
Alright. Thank you for answering that question.
Now we seem to have a small issue.
Is that because I did the Suborbital and
say that the hello world directory? Should I
have done a Suborbital here?
Or
Let's see
let's see, like, an l l what's
in the directory for a moment.
Oh, yeah. It doesn't seem like the bundle
got put.
I just move it. Yeah. You can move
move that bundle up here. Yeah. There you
go.
There we go.
So does that mean I have a web
service running on port eighty eighty that I
can hit a push request to slash hello
and it'll work? Yes.
So it it it seems like running
that build command inside didn't
pull in the directive. So
if we can kill this, we can rebuild
it. It didn't look like the the directive
got pulled in. Otherwise, you would have seen
the different routes.
No. You so
this is something that I need to improve
the documentation on, but just the dot and
then dash dash bundle
should be should be good there.
Yeah. It's the the CLI
and the ATMO itself are the the newer
portions of Suborbital.
So some of the
ergonomics of it is not
quite perfect yet.
Does change in directory mean that my build
context has changed and invalidated the cache?
It shouldn't because
the Docker the Docker builder
gets mounted
to the
runnable directory itself, the crates index thing is
something that I'm working on improving. It doesn't
need to update its crates index every time,
but it yeah. There you go. What now
that all the prerequisites have been precompiled, we
should be good to go. So you can
run that dev command again.
Nice. Okay.
There we go. So now we can see
that first line. It says mounting the route.
That means that we've got all of the
stuff that we need, and it has set
up the application for us.
So now if you, yeah, just make a
post request to slash hello,
we can just see that running real quick.
It is It's up. Yeah.
There you go. So
you can see here it's just returning you
a summary of what the request is.
So it's just telling you that that's what
happened and it's giving you the request ID
that was generated.
And so now we can hop into the
the Rust function and actually do some something
cooler with it.
Right.
So, that you're getting
that's what it's just a summary of what
the request is telling you that it's a
post request. It's giving you the URI and
the and a request
ID. If we want to access the rest
of the request and, you know, get some
more information from it, we use the suborbital
crates to do that. So at the top,
if you could include another of the sub
crates, which is suborbital colon colon rec r
e q
in addition to the yeah. Exactly.
So now we can use that to access
some information about the request. So if we
do yeah. Like,
let's say we want to get the body,
we can say rec colon colon body underscore
raw.
And then Why am I not getting my
auto complete?
That's a good question.
I can't call if it's auto complete.
I find personally that the the Rust
the
what do they call it? The Rust analyzer
needs to be restarted every once in a
while, and that's just my personal I think
I dismissed the message saying, hey. We wanna
update Rust analyzer when I started it. That's
awesome. Yeah. In fact, I'm not even in
the right right now. Let's let's not confuse
it too much. Let me
do that.
Let's see.
Yeah. There we go. Okay.
Not installed. Not that it needs updated.
Wonder why that is. Yeah.
I honestly language servers in general have been
giving me problems lately. Even the go language
server and the rust language server have both
been just causing me issues as of late.
Alright. Well, that is now indexing those libraries
some 10 or 75. So let's assume that's
gonna take thirty seconds.
Yeah. For sure. So I'll I'll talk a
bit more about what those APIs are.
So so the Suborbital Crate,
it's it gives you access
to things outside of the Web module, and
it does so in a very controlled way.
So
this this goes back to the security properties
of WebAssembly. Right? And we can talk for
a second about what those are.
WebAssembly
modules run inside
a, you know, a nice sandbox.
In this case, we're using the Wasmr runtime.
And it means that
only what the host explicitly
grants to the module can be accessed.
And so that means that ATMO and the
the the the the Hive job scheduler can
control exactly
what these modules are allowed to do. And
we do that by providing APIs through this
crate. So I think it looks like it's
working now. We can grab the body raw.
I think that will be a vec, so
we'll wanna make that a string most likely.
Yeah.
Let me if I can remember how to
do that.
There is a util package with Suborbital if
you want to use it because I always
get confused by these. There's a string.
Yeah. It seems okay with that. Yeah. Oh,
no. Cool.
It's okay. You can you can kill most
of the stuff that's inside of the sum,
and we can just return that something if
you if you want.
There is a if you import the util
module from Suborbital, it will give you a
a convenience function to convert vector string.
So that this is yeah. It's the vector
of of base.
Why is there no Yep. Collect.
Okay. Never mind.
And what's that helper function called, sir? Yeah.
So if you import the util module including
in in addition to those two,
then you should be able to do util
colon colon to string, I think it is,
and then pass in the VEC.
Nice. There we go. We have a string.
Yeah.
Cool. And then, you can delete all the
stuff inside line 12 to 14 there, you
can just return something there as your, as
your return value.
Yeah. Something like the variable.
Oh, alright. Oh, okay. Okay.
Actually, no. That's a string. So we're we're
gonna want,
you know what? I don't I I I
think we went a little bit too far.
The, we want to return One space. To
evacuate.
Yeah. So we can we can cancel the
string.
Yeah. I I
I usually do lots of string manipulation with
some of these things, I'm so used to
converting it to string right off the bat.
But yeah. Oh. We can go ahead and
just do that. Raw.
Okay.
And we're retarding that, so we'll leave it
as so. Okay. Cool.
Yeah. You no longer need that. I mean,
you'll wanna change input there to an underscore
just because we're not using it anymore.
The the actual run parameter called input
can be a underscore.
Yeah.
Oh, well, I guess
There we go. There we go. So
so, yeah, what's happening here is when when
a request is being handled
by
this WebAssembly module,
the Atmo will
basically bind
that request to this module, and then we
use these APIs to access more information about
it. So now if you go and build
again,
we can deploy that server.
We can just kinda show that very basic
version of it.
Now that we are After after this build,
we'll set up your native one so that
we can do it lightning fast.
I'm assuming I can just pass through any
strength as the body.
Yep. That's right.
That's that's the thing about WebAssembly is that
because we are
having to pass data
amongst,
you know, guest modules that are written in
different languages, and they're all running inside this
WebAssembly runtime,
we do need to, you know,
transfer stuff around as bytes. There
is something coming very soon into the WebAssembly
spec called
reference types where you will be able to
pass more complex data structures like structs and
whatnot.
And
did that Yeah. It worked.
Okay. Cool. So
that's great. Yeah. So, yeah, reference types will
be added to the WebAssembly spec soon, and
you'll be able to pass more complex data
types. But for now, you you're really limited
to passing around bytes.
Is there any sort of
middleware system where I can inject my own
parsers for, like, you know, HTTP request headers,
deserializing
the body into certain structs or anything like
that?
Yeah. So
that is a for now, the way that
I've I've approached this is I'm providing
convenience things for you through these crates.
But the goal is to eventually remove any
of that custom functionality
in
favor of, you know, the standard language things.
We'll need a little bit more
functionality in the WebAssembly runtime before
we can really do that well.
So,
for example, we can do that right now
if you, for example, if the body was
JSON
and and we wanted to access
a particular part of it, we could take
that body raw and we could, you know,
disassemble it into a struct.
But Suborbital
Crate does provide some,
functions to do this for you. So we
can say let something equal,
there's a body underscore field function
that we can use to actually take the
request JSON,
parse it, and pull fields out of it
automatically.
So, we can just, you know, key hello
or whatever.
Yeah. Sure.
And then
and I think that will return
I'm not sure if that returns a vector
string.
I could just oh, no. Body
field might return bytes as well.
It returns a string.
Oh, okay.
So then you
want to do
I think it's
as bytes to vec or something. Like, you
do as bytes and then dot to vec.
Oh, yeah. Yeah. There we go.
Yeah.
So let's let's quickly set up your native
runtime or your native tool chain so we
can get those super fast builds.
Do you have Rust up installed?
Mhmm. I do.
So if you just do Rust
up tool chain install WASM 32 dash Wazi
I think it's tool chain install.
Let
me let me make sure I'm getting that
right.
Is that
children left foot? Let just get the exact
one for you.
I just keep guessing just Yeah.
So Rust up target add WASM 32 dash
Wazy.
Target add WASM 32 Wazy.
Yeah. That looks better.
Yeah.
Yes.
So these are the kinds of not complicated
to install these various tool chains, but I
did wanna make it extremely easy for somebody
to just get up and running with the
basic version. And then if they want to
add, you know, the the easier
to use parts of it later, they can.
So, yeah, you can hit that command. The
passing the native flag will just allow it
to use your local tool chain.
And
as we can shortly see, this will be
a fair bit faster off the bat than
Docker. And then on that second
run through, it'll be, like, milliseconds.
So see the
well, just well, let's compile on it. So
we're now using request body field name. Now
is that gonna decode whatever JSON I pass
in, or is it expecting me to pass
in query parameters?
What what's the semantics there? Yeah. So that
that yeah. That will pull in, yeah, from
the body, from the request body just like
you have. There are other helper functions for
accessing query params.
We'll look at HTTP,
like, path params as well, headers, all sorts
of things. Those are all provided by the
library
for you to access. Oh, nice. So I
can actually just do, like, this was a
query param where I pass the name as
David or Connor, and it would actually know
to to parse that to.
Yeah. So yeah. We'll we'll we can do
that one in a second and we can
actually control that with the directive as well.
Cool.
Alright. So we've got the JSON parsing.
Yeah.
So yeah. So we can look at HTTP
paths if you want or sorry, URIs.
If we pop open the directive,
it looks like code doesn't have the root
open, but you can just
I'm trying to make this as difficult for
you as possible. That's what that is. You
know? That's alright. Yeah. It's it's it's it's
always a guessing game whether Versus Code will
properly handle multiple crates in the same project
or not. Yeah. So if we just, you
know, after that slash hello,
add a slash colon name,
then that's, you know, setting up a, basically,
a path wildcard,
and we can then access that in our
crates. So if you switch from body field,
I believe it is just param,
rec colon colon param,
I think.
URL param?
Yes. URL param. That's the one.
And then, yeah, same thing, plus name.
And then,
we can go back and see that native
tool chain
in
practice.
See how fast that was this the next
time around.
Alright. And then we should be able to
do
yeah. Kill all of the
so right. We're doing it.
Exactly.
Sweet. Nice. I like it.
Yeah. So those are the kinds of things.
As you can see, like, a lot of
the APIs are designed
around building,
well, web APIs.
That's kind of the focus for now with
Atmo is is really building, you know, like,
the standard REST API.
But,
that's not the end goal, or at least
that's not the entire goal. So the entire
goal
is to be able to handle, you know,
event based traffic. You know, you should be
able to,
attach
Atmo to, you know, a Kafka
message queue or
NATs, and you should be able to handle
any kind of input.
That's one of the nice things about the
Grav project is that it accepts plug ins
for all sorts of different transports.
And so,
connecting to various, you know, messaging or,
queue systems
will be eventually pretty trivial.
And so you should be able to handle
all sorts of different traffic
using Atmo.
But, you know, talk to me in six
months and that'll probably be available.
Alright. So I think we've done a a
good job of showing how we're using Rust
to component to Wasm. We're using the the
runtime here.
Can we now take a look at composition?
Can I add a new endpoint and pass
data from one to the other?
Sure. So let's head back to the terminal
and we can do
Subor create runnable and then give it a
name.
Call it translator.
Sure.
Cool. So, yeah, you should have another one
in there now,
and it'll be empty once again.
And
so we can
you know, what what do you what do
you wanna build here? We can
So why don't we just
take the hello world, which takes a name
on the the URL parameter right now. So
I pass in David or Connor, and why
don't we have to translate or just
reverse the string and spit it back out?
Sure. Sounds great. So this brings us to
the declarative
application building, and this is the part that
gets me pretty excited. So if we open
up that directive,
file for just a moment, I wanna walk
through, some of the basics. So you can
see here in the handler, we name a
number of steps.
And so what's happening here is that each
step in the chain
will produce an output.
So the hello world one will just spit
out the name from the URL.
Every time a step completes,
the output gets saved to what's called the
request state.
And this is, basically a map or, the
key value pairs
that is, you know, constructed for each request.
And
if I wanna access
the state
from one of the runnables,
the Suborbital crates, the the library, will allow
me to do that. So when this hello
world function runs in the first step, its
output will get saved to state.
And then the second step, which will be
our reverse, will be able to access that
state
and pull the value that was output in
the first step
and then use that to do whatever it
wants with.
So
on line 14 right where your cursor is,
we can add another f n,
exactly like the first one,
and we'll say,
translate, I think you called it.
So
this will
now in the translator runnable, we're going to
access that state and figure out what that
hello world function,
gave us. So
you can
use, we're we're gonna import that rec module
again,
because we're gonna be accessing the request state.
And,
yep. And so if you,
do rec colon colon state,
I will put it in a variable. So
let name equal,
you know, rec colon colon state.
Give it a second. See if it catches
up.
Alright. Yeah.
I think it's just a lot of queries.
Let me pop it open and just a
translator.
Yeah. Sure.
Those pesky language servers.
Yeah. They're not I think it's a handle
model ripples really well, I don't think so.
Yeah.
Okay.
Now that looks a bit healthier.
Oh,
I've not done a cargo install yet.
Do I need to or a build? Or
So Versus Code usually does that for you,
but
I mean Well, does this fetching
metadata.
Alright.
So
But I mean, we can run a Suborbital
build and that will build all of the
prerequisites and stuff if you want.
Yeah. Why not?
So So if you just if you're inside
of of a of a runnable,
I mean, yeah, sure. You can do the
whole thing if you want. That'll build all
of them. But if you just wanna run
one,
you can do that as well. But, yeah,
go ahead and do that.
Yeah. It seems a bit happier now.
Potentially.
There we go. Alright. So it just wants
a Yeah.
So we'll just ask for so in this
case, we're gonna ask for hello world
because that was the name of the function.
But that's
not super
ergonomic. So let's go back to the directive,
and we can actually make that a little
bit nicer.
I'm in I'm in limbo.
I'll grab beach ball.
Okay.
Let's open up this whole thing again.
You can just maybe add the directive file
if you don't wanna add the whole thing.
We just got the the most important question
of the day. What is my Versus code
color scheme?
It is It is very nice. This one
is called plastic
I believe.
Panda syntax. It's not plastic. Panda
syntax.
Alright. We wanted the directive.
Okay. So we wanna improve the ergonomics of
the passing first date. Exactly. So so by
default,
the the value
in
state
we want to make that a nicer name.
So underneath the hello world on line 13,
we can add a new line,
and we can say as,
and then a colon, and then
name.
So the
the as clause
is,
one of the things you can use in
the directive to make, you know, the state
easier to work with.
So it basically is like assigning to a
variable. We're saying, run hello world and save
it as name.
So now we can pop back to the
translator,
function.
And instead of requesting it as hello world,
we can just request it as name. And
it makes a lot more sense from the
from the perspective
developer.
So then we can do our magic to
do the reversal. I'm gonna let you handle
this part because a Rust developer, I am
not.
Yeah.
Good. I never really planned this through today.
I will do some quick googling.
Sorry. Unless
you tell me I called it anyway. Don't
mind showing people. So Rust, Rivera, it's a
string.
Yeah. It's looks like .chars.rev
will There we go.
Do it.
Does that return
or does it mutate?
Yeah. Okay. Oh, and then you might wanna
dot collect
from that.
Okay. So reverse
equals.
And because we're doing a collect, we need
to specify the type.
There we go. So now
we can use our util function.
That's right. Oh, no. We don't need it
because it already is. Oh, no. We need
bytes. Okay. Reverse.
Yeah.
Bytes.
Not too back, I think, as well. That's
right. Yep. Thank you.
And this doesn't need to be mutable. Let's
get rid of that yellow squiggle here. Oh,
too much. Too much.
That piece, the compiler.
Alright. Yes.
Great. Okay. So,
now let's just revisit the directive to make
sure that we
are summarizing what's happening.
So we're running the hello world function. That's
returning the name from the URL parameter. We're
saving it into the request state
as name, and then the translator function is
going to run take that name and give
us the reverse version. So we can
build that and
let it run.
Great.
Hey. It worked.
There you go. I mean, of course, it
worked. Like, never ending this.
Hey. In my head, that's what I'm thinking.
Yes.
Composition. Right? You,
you can do all sorts of different things.
Now there's one more little superpower of the
directive that I'd love to show off.
If we could create one more runnable,
I do wanna show some of the powers
that WebAssembly gives us.
So if we create runnable, let's just call
it,
you know, the thingy. Yeah. Sure.
Now,
it it can honestly, we can just leave
it as the default. It doesn't, what it
actually does doesn't matter.
If we pop over to the directive for
a moment,
we can do something pretty cool. So,
let's
say we want to run a bunch of
these functions
in parallel.
Say you wanna do a whole bunch of
data fetching all at once.
Say you want to, you know, connect to
a bunch of different resources and pull in
a bunch of different data. We can use
what's called a function group here. So,
let's go in here. We can just pass
group,
as the instead of f n. And then,
we'll have to go down a line and
then add a couple of f n's to
that group.
So,
yes, I think that should do it. You
never know with YAML indentation,
but
so we can actually put
yeah. We can do that, or we can
we can actually put, you know, the hello
world
in there as well if we want to.
And so what's going to happen here is
that the the job schedule will actually run
all of these functions concurrently,
and then all of their results will be
put into that request state.
So if you wanted to do parallel processing,
if you wanted to, you know, save to
a database and a cache simultaneously,
these are the kinds of things that you
can do yeah. With a function group.
And it's really nice because
you, as the developer,
you don't need to do any of the
logic that you would normally need to do
to run these things concurrently. You know, if
you were a Go developer,
you would have to be dealing with Go
routines. You'd have to be dealing with channels.
You'd have to be making sure that they
all blah blah blah succeeding.
But with this, we just say, hey. We
wanna run these functions in parallel, and the
job scheduler
will figure it out.
So,
you know,
we don't necessarily have to run this because
it's not gonna look any different from an
output perspective, but,
you know, I I do wanna just kinda
point out that these are some of the
things that we can
do with it.
So there's that I think there's two questions
in my mind right now.
Now I'll start with the first one and
then I'll go into well, I guess it
is my they're still in my mind. So
the first question is
is the
the base we are passing back as as
the state of each of these individual functions.
The only way to transfer state between the
functions and then I guess the example I'm
thinking there is if I wanted to do
any form of image manipulation, would I have
to store those bytes of memory and return
them or can I to have it like
shared disk across the invocations at all?
So
currently,
you can't access the disk.
That is something that I will be adding
once I can get Wazee working reliably across
both of the Rust and Swift.
But what you can access as a shared
resource is a cache.
So there is a suborbital API for accessing
a cache. If you want to connect to
Redis or something like that, you can do
so.
I do plan on adding more APIs very
soon, which will let you access more resources
like that. Like, one of the things I
would like to do is give access to,
you know, static files. If you want to
serve,
you know, a static website,
you should be able to include those files
into the bundle and allow,
you know, your runnables to access those files.
So these kinds of things, you know, accessing
shared disk, accessing files, connecting
to more things outside of the modules,
these are all things that I'm designing right
now and I'm working on building up.
But, you know, they each have to be
built individually and they all have their own
security concerns and whatnot. So I'm trying to
be a little extra careful,
with some of those things to make sure
that I'm building them in a way that,
you know, won't let you screw it up.
Alright. And my second question is
like we're now in a stage with us,
you know, directive failed that we have. Our
first step, we then have a group which
runs three in parallel followed by our final
step which is a translator.
If I were to
run this like so, sorry. Let me try
and articulate this question in a way that
makes sense. But I only see
the output from the final step. If I
wanted to debug something in the middle, is
there a
pragmatic way of handling that at the moment?
Yeah. So there's two things that you can
do.
One of them is that the suborbital
package,
provides some logging functions.
So if we want, we can go back
to, you know, the translator, for example, and
we can add a little bit of logging
if you like. And then the other,
the other thing is you can control which
function's output
is used as the response,
and we can do whichever of those two
things you wanna do first.
So if you it just import the log
module.
Then, you know, if you want, yeah, we
can say log colon colon info,
and then just pass in you'll have to
do an as str on that. Or yeah.
That works fine.
So now
you can
we can run that and see that being
logged.
Right off the bat here.
You can see how much faster the data
of full chain is than the Docker one.
So then somewhere in the middle yeah. You
can see stuff and things popping out there.
And so
the other thing that you can do is
if you want to take the output from
a particular function,
we can head back to the directive,
and you can use the response
option.
So right at the end of the handler,
the same level as the steps
key,
We can go right to the very end.
Or yeah. It it doesn't matter. So if
you just say response
colon
and then choose one of the names. So
if you wanted to do thingy
as the
the the output, you can actually tell it
this is the one that I wanna take
the output from to actually respond to the
request with.
So this one will probably just be that
default, once again, the, yeah, the summary of
request because we didn't actually change the thingy
on the phone.
Alright. Cool.
Yeah. And this helps that, like, if the
if the last step in the in the
chain
is a group, right, that there's no logical
way to choose between the functions in that
group. And actually, Suborbital will error out if
you just have a group as the last
step. It will tell you that you must
give a response
field to to make sure that it's unambiguous.
Okay. Is,
as there are docs on this directive file
and all the things that we can
Yeah. Absolutely.
Because like one of the things popping into
my head and probably may not exist yet
would be like,
you know, flow constructs within here. Like if
I could do
for each
and then tell it like it was from
whatever I got from hello world,
you know, maybe it returns
like a the vector base have like something
I could split on and I can say
split on a comma like you know where
I could actually build for loops with obviously
I can do that and
the translator lib. Rs but to build that
into a directive I think would be really
cool and of course maybe like Yeah. Conditionals
too. So only if this far is defined
or whatever and like really starting to build
out complex.
I guess workflow is kind of what I'm
thinking up here.
Absolutely. That's definitely in the plan.
The the four h one particularly,
I was planning on doing that very soon.
I was hoping to get it done for
this livestream, but I haven't quite gotten that
part finished yet. But absolutely. Plus I'm identifying
areas of the project where I can hopefully
come and help out. Because I I mean,
I can see loads of use cases for
a tool like this. Okay. You know, I
like building the dent driven applications
and this is like the perfect thing where
I could just build out all those functions
in isolation and then chain them together with
the composition. It seems like a really powerful
tool. I'm very impressed. Yeah.
Thank you very much. Yeah. It's the
this is one of the things where I
was I was I was developing, you know,
the three building blocks. Right? The hive, vector,
and grav.
And
this this idea, the idea of the directive,
when that was when I kind of
thought of this concept,
that was when it really clicked for me
of what Atmo was going to be.
I I thought it was just gonna be,
you know, you just write code and you
have to call the functions directly with some
Go code or something. And that felt fine,
but I wasn't super excited about it.
And then when this this idea of the
of the directive
came up in my head, that's when I
started to get really excited. And that's the
day that I created you know, I actually
started the Atmo repository
and started actually building it because
that that was the thing that got me
super excited.
Sweet. Excellent.
So we have another
comment on my theme for Kelly Jackson. That's
not what it looks like on mine. Jump
in the Discord. I'll chat you there. We're
not gonna be able to live debug that
here.
Okay. So we've covered sorry for the segue
there. We've covered a fair bit of this.
I'm excited about this tool. I believe you've
got a few more advanced demos that you
may wanna show us.
Sure. Yeah. I will show off, you know,
one or two more bits of the, runnable
API.
Let me make sure. Let's get that screen
share up and running again.
Cool.
Just make sure I'm in the right is
that font big enough, do think? Or you
can make it a bit I mean, it
wouldn't hurt to go in a couple more
for sure, but it's it's readable. Yeah. Yeah.
Okay.
Okay. Cool. So
we're going to go into
I have my own important API,
of course.
So, of course, that opens in the wrong
screen.
Alright. So I've got a runnable here
that this is this is available in the
Suborbital GitHub if anybody wants to take a
look at this one. Could you zoom in
on that a little bit as well, please?
Yeah. Absolutely.
I'll get rid of this bottom and just
make this smaller so that I can really
see it. Okay.
So
so, yes, this is available in the Suborbital
GitHub. It's called important API. That's what you
know, it's it's very,
very useful.
And this it's designed to show off more
of the APIs that are available. So, you
know,
we've we've looked already at, like, RAC, and
we looked at log and util,
but there's one more that I wanna show
off, which is HTTP.
So
by default, you know, WebAssembly can't access the
network.
And in fact, even the Wazi specification,
you know, it still doesn't quite give full
access to networks. There's some things
coming up. There are some things currently in
development. There are some limited things available already.
But I wasn't fully happy with it, and
I wanted to build my kind of own
version of it.
So the Suborbital library provides this HTTP,
module.
And what it lets us do is make
HTTP requests.
So
I've got this runnable here,
and all it's really doing is it's using,
you know, the the rec,
module that we've already looked at. You know,
it's checking the URL param just like we
did a minute ago.
And what it then does is it's gonna
go hit the GitHub API,
and it's just gonna get the details of
whatever repository we pass in, as the the
fields
in the in the URL.
And then we're gonna do something, you know,
pretty pretty standard.
You know, we we access the field directly
in in the example that we did, but
I'm going to just show that this can
be a regular Rust program. Right? You can
use SerDay and you can deserialize
JSON and you can do whatever you want
here. So we are gonna take the response
from that GitHub API request. We are going
to create just a a summary of,
the stargazers, so, like, the star count on
that repo, and then that's what we're gonna
return.
So I'm going to,
build this.
Not build.
We'll give bundle.
And,
obviously, I've built this once already because that
was super fast. And then we're going to
start
this up in my other terminal here.
Suborbital dev.
And
wow. It really oh, something's already listening
on that port, apparently.
What do I have running? Apparently, I already
have one running.
Let's try this again.
There we go.
I'm gonna clear
this. I hope that last one wasn't important.
No. I'm pretty sure that was just me
preparing for this demo.
Right. So you can see, you know, we're
mounting this this
route.
It has a
different style of wildcard that lets us pass
any kind of path that we want. And
so we're gonna hit local host eighty eighty
slash stars,
and we'll do, like, Suborbital ATMO, for example.
And as soon as we hit that,
it is going to execute that g h
stars function,
and then it's gonna return to us information
from that GitHub API. And we can see
that it did,
you know, do some logging, fetching stars for
Suborbital ATMO,
and it did all of the JSON parsing
with SerDay, etcetera, etcetera.
And so, you know, this is just one
of the other APIs.
And then the last one, that we can
just take a quick look at is, the
ability to access the cache. So say I
wanted to,
you know, cache this this API response.
There is one more,
here that we can access. Probably should make
it the first one.
The Suborbital cache,
one. So we can say
cache
set.
That is not colon.
And then we can say we wanna set,
you know
we'll call it the we'll say we'll put
a repo as the key because we want
it to be specific to the repo that
we are
requesting for.
And then the value can be,
those repo details,
and then we'll set the TTL to zero
so it never dies.
And
so
then
oh, this is gonna yell at me, isn't
it? Borrower group value. And we need to
do, I think, as owned?
No.
Two clone. Yeah. Okay.
Oh, yeah. Clone. Yes.
See, I'm getting a lesson right here on
some Rust best practices.
So so then, you know, the the nice
thing about WebAssembly and and Atmo is that
you as the developer, you don't need to
care
about the cache, what it is, what it's
connected to, you know, how it's configured.
The cache is bound
at runtime.
And so all of your functions can use
this API.
And then maybe in local development, it's using
an in memory cache, but then in production,
it could use Redis or Memcache or whatever.
And you as a developer don't need to
care. You just bind to this this API,
and it will figure itself out at runtime.
So, yeah, those are just a couple of
the extra,
you know, pieces of functionality that it has.
More coming.
The thing that I'm working on right now,
is
accessing databases.
I think that's kind of the last big
piece
to really make this,
usable for the kind of average
API application,
access to a cache and access to a
database. Those are, like, kind of the very
bare minimum things that you need.
So, hopefully, within a month or two, there
will be a, you know, suborbital DB here
that you can use to
do some SQL queries or maybe it'll be
GraphQL. I don't know. We'll we'll see where
we end up with that.
Yeah.
Awesome. Very, very cool. I like it.
Thanks. So we've we've covered quite
a lot. I hope that gives the people
that are watching an idea of you know,
the project,
what is use cases are, why you would
wanna use it. You even give us a
little bit of extra what's coming kind of
next day as well, which is also fantastic.
Is there, I mean we kind of deviated
right? We paved our own path there instead
of even using your brand new documentation. I
feel a bit bad there but I still
feel that we should have the
platform, the docs are here for anyone who
wants to pop in through.
So I'll leave you with with this then.
How can people contribute?
What do you want help with? And is
there anything else that we haven't covered that
you wanna just quickly drop in at the
end there?
Yeah. Absolutely. So for con for contributions,
literally anything.
And I say that with the broadest sense.
So
it doesn't matter if you are a Go
developer. It doesn't matter if you've never used
WebAssembly before. It doesn't matter, you know, what
operating system you're using.
I
I want
anybody to be able to contribute to this.
And,
you know, whether it's documentation,
whether it's working on, you know, the CLI,
whether it's working on the job scheduler, any
of the components, really,
I'm I'd love to have people come and
and help build these things.
In particular, you know, I like I've said
more than once here, I'm not a Rust
developer.
And we didn't even get a chance to
dig into the Swift portions of things, bit
because there is a support
for for Swift here as well. Swift developers
as well. You know, anybody with with
experience in those languages,
very much appreciated any help that they could
give.
And then I want to bring additional language
support as well. So, you know, c, c
plus plus developers, anyone with a
who's used AssemblyScript
and wants to come in and build that
with us,
you know, that that's really fantastic. And then
even if you're don't want to contribute
code,
use
Atmo
and
find where it breaks.
That is one of the best things that
you can do and
help me get it from the alpha that
it is today to something that can be
used for real world workloads.
Show me where it doesn't work for you,
not just from, like, a crash or a
bug, but ergonomically. Where does it feel awkward?
Where do you see it as being inferior
to building an application the old fashioned way?
Any of those types of things are are
always immensely helpful.
And then taking that survey. So the, the
bit.ly/wasm
survey,
I wanna know, you know it it's it's
really just five or six questions about languages,
capabilities,
and, you know, things that you would want
to see from this type of framework and
platform.
And I've forgotten what your second question was.
Yeah. Was there anything else that we haven't
mentioned that you wanna quickly add on?
Oh, that's right. The
Atmo itself is fantastic,
and I you know, that's my main focus.
But the individual
projects
are also completely usable on their own. If
you just need a job scheduler,
Hive is fantastic. If you want to just
make building
APIs in Go simpler, Vector is really great.
If you want a decentralized message bus, Grav
is fantastic. And,
contributing plug ins for Grav, for example, would
be really great. They are,
super easy to build and, you know, the
documentation is not fantastic,
but
it's it's really fun to to build on.
And I've I'm really quite happy with how
that project is coming out. So,
you know, any and all of the projects
are open for new users and and contributors.
Alright. Awesome. Well,
thank you very much for for getting up
early joining me today
for your work on at more and web
assembly and providing tools to make this easier
for people to adopt.
Really good to see. Cheers. It's been great.
And I'll let you into a little secret.
My secret power is breaking software. So give
me a couple of days with us and
I will find you the bugs that you're
looking for.
That sounds great. Alright. Well, thank you again.
I hope you have a great day. I'm
looking forward to seeing where this and I'll
speak to you again soon. Thank you, Connor.
Yeah. Cheers. Thanks so much.